you
a subscriber J wrote to me to tell me
that he wants to start a flower shop and
asked me how he could stand out now the
flower industry is brutal ridiculously
Google margins are being cleaned by
supermarkets and online stores there are
fewer flower growers making it harder to
find locally grown products it's one of
the most competitive online businesses
so good luck with getting people to
search and find your website when the
economy is down luxury items like
flowers are the first thing people stop
spending money on the big referral
partners like funeral parlors and
banquet hall already have long-standing
relationship with Florida then who wants
to be in the flower business Jade so I
was going to help the secret was for
jada realized that he wasn't selling
flowers it was telling something much
more powerful day was really selling
calm what I learned from Jay was that he
loves flowers because they make them
feel calm if he stressed the word he
looked at the flowers and he comes up
that discourse for jay to avoid not to
failure and beat the odds he needs that
a break come and it's so much more than
just having great cloud his store should
be a haven for people who want to feel
calm he should sell flowers that make
people come you should have signage
outside that makes people feel calm we
should play music higher fat greet
people will the air with sense and have
a slore layout that makes people cause
you should get involved with charities
that help people being stressed and if
we're coming trauma populist jay or
anyone on this team should make you feel
for him to be successful he's others to
experience the calm feeling that he
loves getting from his flowers and it's
easy to do it doesn't have to be safe
it's not just a marketing strategy
because that's Jake is you just need it
embraces and share it then this flower
shop will become a destination for
people who want to become ill attract
people will naturally get along with who
will buy more flowers spend more money
prefer more customers and we'll compare
him to the does most apply online the
night that cools down and it applies
them much more than just Sally it's a
philosophy for how you run your entire
business and your life almost nobody
does it and it's your chance to dominate
your industry
you